THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
FOR BEING HERE. BRIGHT KIND OF
BRIGHT. AND EARLY THIS MORNING
AS BRIGHT AS IT'S GOING TO BE,
WE ARE HOLDING OUR HEARING TODAY
IN ROOM 2200 OF THE Ó STREET
BUILDING. I ASK ALL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO COME TO THE
HEARING ROOM SO THAT WE CAN
BEGIN THE HEARING. WE HAVE 81
MEASURES ON TODAY'S AGENDA. ONLY
ONE OF WHICH IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
Dð PASS MOTION. THE REMAINING
ITEMS ARE SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. WE HAVE ONE SUSPENSE
FILE BILL THAT WILL HAVE A
PRESENTATION, BUT THE AUTHORS
FOR THE REMAINING SUSPENSE BILLS
HAVE WAIVED PRESENTATION. WE
WILL BE TAKING TESTIMONY FROM
THE PUBLIC ON EACH AND EVERY
ITEM, EVEN IF THE AUTHOR HAS
WAIVED PRESENT PRESENTATION. SO
DON'T WORRY, WE WILL GET TO YOU
EVEN IF THE AUTHOR IS NOT HERE.
AB 1886 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ AND AB 2618 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHEN ARE STILL LISTED ON
THE DAILY FILE, BUT THESE
MEASURES WILL BOTH BE
RESCHEDULED TO OUR NEXT HEARING
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS. AS
USUAL, WE WILL EXTEND A COURTESY
TO ANY MEMBERS SHOWING UP IN
PERSON AND ALLOW THEM TO PRESENT
THEIR BILL OUT OF AGENDA ORDER
AS THEY SHOW UP. SO BEFORE WE
BEGIN, I WANT TO REMIND ANY
WITNESSES TO LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL ASPECTS
OF THE BILL. THIS IS THE FISCAL
COMMITTEE, AND WE LOOK AT THE
COST TO THE STATE. PLEASE
REFRAIN FROM LENGTHY POLICY
DISCUSSIONS AND REPEATING PRIOR
TESTIMONY IN YOUR COMMENTS.
BEFORE WE BEGIN HEARING
TESTIMONY ON THE MEASURES BEFORE
US TODAY, WE'RE GOING TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MADAM
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
REQUIRED FOR THE QUORUM. NEVER
MIND. I GUESS WE WON'T. WE NEED
ONE MORE MEMBER. SO WE WILL
ESTABLISH THAT QUORUM BEFORE WE
CAN TAKE UP ANY MOTIONS. SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
BUSINESS OF THE DAY. SO SINCE WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE
THE TESTIMONY AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
UNTIL WE GET ENOUGH MEMBERS. I
GOT TOO EXCITED ABOUT STARTING
OFF. SO WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
IS START WITH, THE FIRST BILL,
WHICH IS AB 311 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO. AS I INDICATED,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON DIRECTLY TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYBODY THAT
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
CHRISTIAN BELTRAN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY
ASSOCIATED WITH THE GENERAL
FUND. COST PRESSURES THAT RANGE
APPROXIMATELY BY 1.7 BILLION
INCHES 24, 25 AND 1.6 BILLION
AND ONGOING BEGINNING IN 2526.
ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL WOULD
RESULT IN ANNUAL STATE OPERATION
COSTS OF ABOUT $1.7 MILLION. IN
GENERAL FUND IN 2425, AND
ADDITIONAL 1.6 MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND ONGOING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO IMPLEMENT
EXPANSION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, ANYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? CONCERNS? SEEING NONE,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON. MOVE ON
TO AB. 457 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL? ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. THERE IS NO
FILE ON THIS. SO WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE
COMMENTS, QUESTIONS, CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL MOVE ON TO AB
2587 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGAIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? 2587? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. NO FILE.
COMMITTEE. NO QUESTIONS. WE'LL
MOVE ON TO AB 27. OH THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL? WELCOME. HI. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
CATHY MCDONALD FOR ALAMEDA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FILE. VERY GOOD.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NONE,
WE'LL MOVE ON TO AB 3203 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGAIN, SHE HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT ABOUT TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. VERY GOOD
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE. WE'LL
MOVE ON. AB 660 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE IN SUPPORT? GOOD MORNING.
SAVANNAH JORGENSEN ON BEHALF OF
THE LUTHERAN OFFICE OF PUBLIC
POLICY, CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NO FILE. WE'RE GOOD.
COMMITTEE NO COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS. MOVING ON TO AB 2320
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN. SHE
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. MAINLY ASSOCIATED
WITH THE GENERAL FUND. COST
PRESSURES FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE, SPECIFICALLY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE, ESTIMATE THAT THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE $681,000 IN 2526
FROM THE GENERAL FUND AND
$654,000 IN THE GENERAL FUND IN
26, 27 AND ONGOING, AND IT WOULD
REQUIRE THREE POSITIONS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT, THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION INDICATES
THAT ANY COSTS RESULTING FROM
THIS BILL ARE MINOR AND
ABSORBABLE, AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE CONCURS WITH BOTH OF
THESE ESTIMATES. VERY GOOD.
SEEING NO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS, I JUST SAW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA WALK IN
HIDDEN OVER THERE. IF YOU'D
LIKE, WE CAN TAKE YOUR MATTER
OUT OF ORDER SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
AB 2271 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ORTEGA. WE HAVE A QUORUM. WE DO.
IF I COULD TAKE A MINUTE AND WE
CAN TAKE ROLL RIGHT NOW.
CABALLERO HERE. CABALLERO HERE.
JONES. ASHBY HERE. ASHBY HERE.
BECKER. BECKER HERE BRADFORD.
CIERTO. CIERTO HERE. WAHAB.
WAHHAB HERE. WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. IT'S YOUR LUCKY DAY.
WELCOME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER AB
2271. GOOD MORNING SENATORS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB 2271 TODAY. AB 2271
IS AN URGENT BILL THAT WILL HELP
AVOID THE CLOSURE OF SAINT ROSE
HOSPITAL IN MY DISTRICT. SAINT
ROSE HOSPITAL IS A SAFETY NET
HOSPITAL IN HAYWARD THAT TREATS
MOSTLY LOW INCOME MEDI-CAL AND
MEDICARE PATIENTS. IT HAS THE
ONLY EMERGENCY ROOM AND
MATERNITY WARD IN THE CITY OF
HAYWARD. SAINT ROSE CURRENT
FINANCIAL SITUATION IS DIRE. THE
HOSPITAL WILL FACE BANKRUPTCY
AND POSSIBLE CLOSURE IN THE NEXT
SIX MONTHS. IF ANOTHER ENTITY
DOES NOT ACQUIRE THE HOSPITAL.
IF SAINT ROSE WERE TO CLOSE,
THEN MORE THAN 150,000 RESIDENTS
OF HAYWARD WOULD BE LEFT WITHOUT
A SAFETY NET. HOSPITAL
ADDITIONALLY, NEARBY HOSPITALS
WOULD BE OVERWHELMED FINANCIALLY
AND WORKLOAD WISE. ALAMEDA
HEALTH SYSTEM HAS COME FORWARD A
STATE CREATED HOSPITAL SYSTEM
THAT IS IN THE BIDDING PROCESS
TO BUY SAINT ROSE, BUT IN ORDER
FOR THIS TO HAPPEN, IT REQUIRES
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE IN THE FORM
OF LOAN FORGIVENESS TO AID
ALAMEDA HEALTH SYSTEM IN
ACQUIRING SAINT ROSE AND
AVOIDING ANOTHER CLOSURE. IN
THIS STATE. THIS BILL WOULD
FORGIVE THE HOSPITAL $17 MILLION
LOAN FROM THE DISTRESSED
HOSPITAL LOAN PROGRAM. THIS BILL
ALSO INCLUDES AN URGENCY CLAUSE.
GIVEN THE SHORT TIMELINE WE HAVE
TO SAVE THIS HOSPITAL THE COST
OF AB 2271 WILL FAR OUTWEIGH THE
BY THE POSITIVE PATIENT OUTCOMES
ASSOCIATED WITH KEEPING SAINT
ROSE OPEN IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
20, AND FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITNESSES TODAY IN
SUPPORT ARE JAMES JACKSON, CEO
OF ALAMEDA HEALTH SYSTEM, AND
MICHAEL SORRELL WITH SAINT ROSE
HOSPITAL. VERY GOOD. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. YOU MAY YOU MAY
PRESENT. YES GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS MICHAEL SERRAO. I'M THE
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR SAINT ROSE
HOSPITAL AND HAVE BEEN SINCE
2013. SAINT ROSE IS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB 2271 AND THANKS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA FOR
INTRODUCING THE BILL, SENATOR
WAHAB FOR COAUTHORING IT AND THE
CHAIR IN THIS COMMITTEE FOR
HEARING THIS BILL TODAY. SAINT
ROSE IS A STAND ALONE,
STANDALONE, NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL THAT HAS SERVED THE
RESIDENTS OF HAYWARD SINCE 1968
AS A STANDALONE, NONPROFIT
SAFETY NET PROVIDER. IT FACES A
NUMBER OF FINANCIAL CHALLENGES
FOR THE FISCAL YEAR ENDING
SEPTEMBER 30, 2023, IT LOST $9.8
MILLION, AND FOR THE FIRST SEVEN
MONTHS OF ITS CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR, IT'S LOST $13.9 MILLION.
SAINT ROSE CAN'T SURVIVE ON ITS
OWN. IT NEEDS TO BE PART OF A
LARGER HEALTH SYSTEM. AND TO
EVERYONE'S CREDIT, SAINT ROSE'S
BOARD OF DIRECTORS SOUGHT OUT A
LARGER HEALTH SYSTEM AND HAS
ENTERED INTO AN EXCLUSIVE,
NON-BINDING LETTER OF INTENT
WITH ALAMEDA HEALTH SYSTEM TO
EXPLORE SAINT ROSE BECOMING PART
OF ALAMEDA HEALTH SYSTEM. SAINT
ROSE HAS, ASSEMBLYMEMBER ORTEGA
SAID, IS CRITICAL TO THE
COMMUNITY. THERE'S AT LEAST
28,000 VISITS TO SAINT ROSE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT EACH YEAR,
AND THE 80 TO 84% OF THOSE ARE
FROM EITHER MEDICARE, MEDI-CAL
OR INDIGENT PATIENTS. IT IS A
TRUE SAFETY NET PROVIDER FOR
SOUTHERN ALAMEDA COUNTY. IF IT
WAS TO CLOSE THE OTHER AREA,
HOSPITALS COULD NOT HANDLE THOSE
28,000 VISITS. WE KNOW THAT BOTH
FROM THE OTHER AREA HOSPITALS
AND A STUDY THAT WAS PERFORMED
IN ORDER FOR SAINT ROSE TO BE
ABLE TO JOIN ALAMEDA HEALTH
SYSTEMS, A NUMBER OF OBSTACLES
TO HAVE TO BE OVERCOME,
INCLUDING SAINT ROSE'S DEBT,
WHICH INCLUDES THE $17.65
MILLION DISTRESSED HOSPITAL
LOAN. SO WE'RE ASKING TODAY FOR
THIS BILL TO WOULD FORGIVE THAT
DISTRESSED HOSPITAL LOAN, WHICH
WOULD ELIMINATE A LARGE A LARGE
OBSTACLE TO SAINT ROSE BECOMING
PART OF ARS AND ALAMEDA HEALTH
SYSTEM PRESENTS A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE ITS MISSION
IS TO SERVE THE SAME PATIENTS AT
SAINT ROSE SERVES AND IS BEST
ALIGNED. WE LOOK FOR OTHER
PARTNERS, BUT ARS IS TRULY THE
BEST PARTNER TO ALLOW SAINT ROSE
TO SURVIVE AND FOR GIVING. THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW ALAMEDA HEALTH
SYSTEM TO INVEST IN SAINT ROSE
WHILE CONTINUING ITS MISSION AT
ALAMEDA HEALTH SYSTEM WITH THEIR
OTHER HOSPITALS THAT SERVE THE
MOST NEEDY PATIENTS IN THE
COUNTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY. MY NAME IS JAMES JACKSON.
I AM THE CEO OF THE ALAMEDA
HEALTH SYSTEM, AND I COME TO YOU
TODAY REPRESENTING OUR HEALTH
SYSTEM WITH A PROFOUND APPEAL
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB 2271
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA, I OFFER
MY SINCEREST GRATITUDE FOR YOUR
AUTHORSHIP OF THIS BILL, THIS
LEGISLATION IS CRITICAL IN
SAFEGUARDING VITAL HEALTH CARE
ACCESS FOR THE RESIDENTS OF
HAYWARD, CALIFORNIA, AND THE
BROADER REGION. SAINT ROSE
HOSPITAL IS ONE OF ONLY THREE
ACUTE GENERAL CARE
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE HOSPITALS
IN OUR COUNTY, AND WE BELIEVE IT
STANDS AS A BEACON OF CARE IN
OUR COMMUNITY. HOWEVER, IT
CONFRONTS ACUTE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES. I'M HERE TODAY TO
URGE YOU TO HELP PREVENT A
HOSPITAL CLOSURE. I ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER THE RAMIFICATIONS OF
SUCH A POTENTIAL CLOSURE. 75% OF
SAINT ROSE HOSPITAL'S EMERGENCY
ROOM VISITS ARE BY SENIORS, AS
WELL AS LOW INCOME PATIENTS WHO
QUALIFY FOR MEDICARE AND OR
MEDI-CAL OR INDIGENT PATIENTS
WITH NO HEALTH INSURANCE AT ALL.
THE SAINT ROSE ED CONTINUES TO
OPERATE AT MORE THAN 100% OF ITS
STANDARD CAPACITY, AND WE
BELIEVE THAT IF SAINT ROSE
HOSPITAL WERE TO CLOSE, IT WOULD
HAVE A RIPPLE EFFECT THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTY'S ALREADY FULL
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS. THE DATA
THAT WE HAVE SHOWS THAT THE
NEIGHBORING HOSPITALS WOULD BE
OVERWHELMED IF THEY SAW FROM 10
TO 15,000 MORE VISITS FROM SAINT
ROSE. AND AS MR. SORRELL
MENTIONED LAST YEAR, THEY DID
ABOUT 28,000. WE BELIEVE THERE'S
HOPE. THE ALAMEDA HEALTH SYSTEM,
APPRECIATING THE URGENCY OF THIS
SITUATION, HAS EMBARKED UPON A
90 DAY EXCLUSIVE RELATIONSHIP
WITH SAINT ROSE THAT WILL END
VERY SOON. OUR OVERARCHING
OBJECTIVE IS RESOLUTE TO
INTEGRATE SAINT ROSE HOSPITAL
INTO THE ALAMEDA HEALTH SYSTEM,
WHICH IS A SAFETY NET HEALTH
SYSTEM, THEREBY PRESERVING ITS
INDISPENSABLE SERVICES AND
ENSURING THE WELFARE OF OUR
COMMUNITY. HOWEVER, A FORMIDABLE
OBSTACLE LOOMS IN OUR PATH.
SAINT ROSE'S HOSPITAL'S
OUTSTANDING CAPITAL DEBT THIS
DEBT IMPERILS OUR ENDEAVORS AND
JEOPARDIZES THE WELFARE OF OUR
COMMUNITY. THAT'S WHERE AB 2271
COMES IN. THIS LEGISLATION
AUTHORIZING THE FORGIVENESS OF
SAINT ROSE HOSPITAL'S DISTRESSED
HOSPITAL LOAN CLEARS THE PATHWAY
FOR OUR ACQUISITION, AND IT
ENSURES THAT MORE THAN 28,000
PATIENT VISITS CAN CONTINUE. FOR
THOSE WHO RELY ON SAINT ROSE
HOSPITAL EACH YEAR, ARS IS THE
ONLY PUBLIC HOSPITAL AUTHORITY
THAT IS SEEKING TO SAVE A
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL, AND WE NEED
YOUR HELP BY SUPPORTING AB 2271,
YOU ARE NOT MERELY ENACTING
LEGISLATION. YOU'RE CHAMPIONING
THE HEALTH AND WELFARE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR POSTERITY. I
IMPLORE YOU TO RECOGNIZE THE
GRAVITY OF THIS MATTER, TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE NEED AND TO
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH US IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2271. TOGETHER, WE
CAN ENSURE THAT NO INDIVIDUAL IS
DEPRIVED OF THE HEALTH CARE THEY
NEED AND THEY DESERVE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HELLO.
ANDY MARTINEZ PATTERSON, CEO OF
THE ALAMEDA HEALTH CONSORTIUM,
REPRESENTING EIGHT FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS IN
ALAMEDA WHO SERVE 300,000 LOW
INCOME PATIENTS IN THE EAST BAY.
AND WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF AB 271
AND THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA
FOR PREVENT PRESERVING ACCESS IN
THE GREATER HAYWARD AREA. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
CATHY MCDONALD FOR THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I'M
MARY ELLEN FARRELL WITH THE EDEN
TOWNSHIP HEALTH CARE DISTRICT.
I'M A DIRECTOR AND I SUPPORT AB
2271 IN, KEEP SAINT ROSE OPEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI. I'M ROXANNE LEWIS, I'M WITH
EDEN HEALTH DISTRICT, AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2251 FOR THE
SUPPORT OF SAINT ROSE HOSPITAL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON. SENATORS. I'M
GARRETT CONTRERAS. I'M THE CHAIR
OF THE SAINT ROSE HOSPITAL BOARD
OF DIRECTORS, AND I STAND IN
SUPPORT. AND THANK YOU FOR
HEARING THIS ITEM. AB 2271.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I AM KATRINA ROSSINI,
AND I'M ALSO ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. AND I FULLY SUPPORT
AS WELL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. I WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA
AND SENATOR WAHAB FOR THIS
LEGISLATION. MY NAME IS ELISA
MARQUEZ, ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISOR, DISTRICT TWO, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SAVING THIS
CRITICAL HEALTH CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS MARK SALINAS. I HAVE THE
HONOR AND THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING
THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
HAYWARD. I WANTED TO THANK OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA AND OUR
SENATOR WAHAB, AND ALSO I WAS
BORN AT SAINT ROSE HOSPITAL, AND
I ABSOLUTELY ENDORSE AND SUPPORT
AB 2271. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE. HI.
GOOD MORNING, DANIEL GOLDSTEIN,
HAYWARD CITY COUNCIL MEMBER I AM
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2271 AND THANK
THE SENATOR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR THEIR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I
AM ANGELA ANDREWS, HAYWARD CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER. I WANT TO THANK
THE SENATOR AS WELL AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR THIS BILL
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HELLO, I'M JULIE ROSE
HAYWARD CITY COUNCIL. I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR WAHAB AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ORTEGA FOR SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. AND I AM ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF 2271. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS ANNETTE SANDERS. I REPRESENT
GLAD TIDINGS CHURCH. I WOULD
LIKE TO, EXTEND MY WARM THANKS
TO ASSEMBLYMAN AND LIZ ORTEGA
FOR THIS BILL. AND WE DEFINITELY
FOR IT. PLEASE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MY NAME IS ED
HERNANDEZ. VERY THANKFUL FOR THE
TIME SUPPORT OF AB 22271. THANK
YOU. MA'AM. ASSEMBLYMAN ORTEGA,
THANK YOU, SENATOR WAHAB, FOR
THE TIME. BUT EDEN HEALTH
DISTRICT, DISTRICT DIRECTOR AT
HERNANDEZ, THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MICHAEL COBB WITH
THE SAINT ROSE HOSPITAL
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
, THANK YOU. HI. I'D LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR WAHAB AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIZ ORTEGA FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN THIS. MY NAME IS
DAVIDA SCOTT AND I'M THE TEACHER
AT THE HAYWARD ADULT SCHOOL. I
OVERSEE RAISING LEADERS. I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2271, AND WE ALSO
HAVE OUR STUDENTS INTERNING AT
SAINT ROSE HOSPITAL, AND I'M
THANKFUL FOR THEM WORKING BESIDE
OUR STUDENTS AND RAISING UP THE
NEXT WORKFORCE OF OUR NATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO
EVERYONE. MY NAME IS FATIMA
PEREZ AND I AM A RAISING STUDENT
AND I SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS CASSANDRA MARQUEZ. I'M A
HAYWARD ADULT SCHOOL RAISING
LEADERS TEACHER AND I SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS BRITTANY NOGUEIRA AND I'M A
HAYWARD ADULT SCHOOL RAISING
LEADER INTERN. I SUPPORT AB
2271. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
HELLO. MY NAME IS NATALIE
SALCIDO. I'M A RAISING HAYWARD
ADULT SCHOOL RAISING LEADERS
TEACHER AND I SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU FOR BRINGING ALL
YOUR STUDENTS TODAY AS WELL.
WE'RE ALWAYS EXCITED TO SEE
THEM. HELLO, MY NAME IS NICOLE
PEREZ AND I'M A HAYWARD ADULT
SCHOOL RAISING LEADERS TEACHER,
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB 2271.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? WELL, IT'S
GREAT TO SEE THE STUDENTS HERE.
AND I'M HAPPY TO HAVE YOU HERE
TODAY. IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? OKAY. SEEING NO ONE
IN OPPOSITION FINANCE? NO FILE.
MADAM CHAIR, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. LET ME JUST, JUMP IN
HERE AND SET THE FRAME, FOR THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE HERE, THIS IS
THE COMMITTEE THAT DOES NOT LOOK
AT POLICY. WE LOOK AT FINANCES.
AND, LAST YEAR WE HAD A WHOLE
SERIES OF HOSPITALS THAT WERE AT
RISK OF CLOSING, THE ONE IN MY
DISTRICT CLOSED, AND IT WAS IT
WAS THE ONLY COUNTY. IT WAS THE
ONLY HOSPITAL IN THE COUNTY, AND
SO THOSE SERVICES HAVE HAD TO GO
ELSEWHERE. AND IT'S BEEN A
DEVASTATING ACTUALLY, IT WAS TWO
YEARS AGO BECAUSE WE'RE GOING ON
TWO YEARS. WE CREATED THE
DISTRESSED HOSPITAL LOAN PROGRAM
AS A WAY TO SAVE HOSPITALS, AND
IT'S SET UP AS A LOAN. BUT WE
ALWAYS UNDERSTOOD THAT THAT LOAN
COULD BE FORGIVEN AT SOME DATE
IN THE FUTURE. ONCE FINANCES
WERE PROVIDED TO THE STATE, SO
THAT WE'RE NOT FUNDING THINGS
THAT ARE GOING TO CLOSE ANYWAY,
THAT WE'RE BEING REALLY WISE
ABOUT OUR MONEY. AND SO, SO
THERE'S, THERE'S THAT, THAT
DISTRESSED LOAN HOSPITAL PROGRAM
AND THEN THERE'S THE ATTACKS
THAT WAS IMPOSED ON THE
COMPLICATED, BUT IT WAS IMPOSED
ON THE INSURANCE AGENTS, THE
INSURANCE GROUPS THAT INSURE,
PEOPLE THAT ARE EMPLOYED AND
HAVE INSURANCE THROUGH THEIR
EMPLOYER. AND THAT IS SUPPOSED
TO INCREASE REIMBURSEMENT TO
HOSPITALS AND DOCTORS AND
DENTISTS FOR PEOPLE WHO, GET
MEDI-CAL SO THAT THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES. BUT ALSO WE WILL HAVE
MORE ACCESS BECAUSE WE EXTENDED
COVERAGE TO A COUPLE MILLION
MORE PEOPLE THAT HERETOFORE HAD
NEVER HAD INSURANCE COVERAGE. SO
RIGHT NOW, EVERYBODY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS COVERED
BY ONE OF THE PROGRAMS, WHICH IS
A GREAT, FEAT. BUT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH DOCTORS, NURSES,
DENTISTS, PSYCHOLOGISTS. AND SO
WE NEED YOU ALL TO GO AND BECOME
THOSE THINGS SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE SERVICES. AND SO, SO
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE IS VERY,
VERY CLOSE TO MY HEART, AND, AND
MY HOSPITAL THAT HAS YET TO OPEN
IS GOING TO NEED A FORGIVENESS
AS WELL. AND SO, IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING H. Kò IS LOOKING
AT A PROCESS TO BE ABLE TO GO
THROUGH THAT. THIS IS A IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. SO I DON'T
WANT YOU TO BE DISAPPOINTED
TODAY. ANYTHING HAVING TO DO
WITH MONEY HAS TO GO TO
SUSPENSE. AND THEN WE WORK
THROUGH A PROCESS OVER THE NEXT
MONTH AND WE'LL KNOW WHETHER
IT'S GOING TO GET OUT OR NOT.
BUT, BUT UNDERSTAND THAT I
THINK, ALL OF US AGREE THAT
SAVING OUR HOSPITALS IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. AND MY
HOSPITAL IS IN MADERA. THEY'RE
COMING BACK AND THEY WILL NOT
PROVIDE, LABOR AND DELIVERY
SERVICES, WHICH IS A NUMBER ONE
ISSUE IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT WE
NEED SERVICES FOR, SO THAT EVEN
WHEN YOU GET A HOSPITAL, YOU CAN
SAVE THEM OR THEY CLOSE OR YOU,
THEY GET THEM OUT OF BANKRUPTCY.
IT'S REALLY, REALLY HARD BECAUSE
WE'VE GOT TO WE'VE GOT TO FIX
OUR SYSTEM AND WE'VE GOT TO,
MAKE IT MORE COST EFFECTIVE TO
TREAT PEOPLE, KEEP THEM HEALTHY,
NOT WAIT UNTIL THEY GET SICK. SO
THAT'S MY SOAPBOX, AND I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO THE CO AUTHOR,
SENATOR WAHAB, TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS. AND THEN WE'LL ALSO
CHECK IN WITH SENATOR SATO.
THANK YOU, ONE, I JUST WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU GUYS FOR COMING
HERE AND CHECKING OUT FROM
HAYWARD. I KNOW IT'S LIKE A VERY
LONG DRIVE, AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIZ ORTEGA FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THIS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. I THINK
THAT JUST AS A COUNCIL MEMBER
AND I'M GLAD WE HAVE THE
MAJORITY OF THE CITY COUNCIL
FROM HAYWARD HERE SHOWING
SUPPORT, SAINT ROSE IS OBVIOUSLY
A VERY CRUCIAL HOSPITAL TO THE
REGION. IT'S NOT JUST FOR
HAYWARD. IT IS LITERALLY THE
ENTIRE REGION. AND CLEARLY BASED
ON THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF WHO WE
SERVE, WE SERVE THE MOST
VULNERABLE. RIGHT. AND I'M GLAD
THAT MY OFFICE WAS THE ONE THAT
WAS REALLY PUSHING THE
DISTRESSED HOSPITAL LOAN TO SO
MANY OF THE HOSPITALS IN THE
AREA, BUT FIRST AND FOREMOST,
THE ONE THAT CAME TOP OF MIND
WAS SAINT ROSE. RIGHT. WE KNOW
THAT HISTORICALLY, SAINT ROSE
HAS STRUGGLED JUST BECAUSE OF
WHO THEY SERVE, RIGHT. AND
THAT'S NOT FAIR, SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ENTIRE CITY
COUNCIL AND THE MAYOR AS WELL AS
SUPERVISOR MARQUEZ FOR SHOWING
UP HERE. I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT, AS THE CHAIR HAS HAS
STATED THAT THIS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND THERE'S A LOT OF
HOSPITALS IN NEED. AND THE MONEY
WAS JUST GIVEN OUT. SO, YOU
KNOW, YOU HAVE TO THINK OF THE,
THE DYNAMICS OF THAT. BUT MAKING
SURE THAT THE NEXT STEP IS THAT
WE ALL WORK TO SEND A LETTER TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
ACCESS AND INFORMATION HCCI, AS
WELL AS, YOU KNOW, THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND MUCH MORE.
AND I KNOW THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ORTEGA WILL SPEARHEAD THAT, BUT
I REALLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT,
BECAUSE IF WE ARE FIRST AND WE
ARE STATING THAT, HEY, ALAMEDA
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS IS ALSO IN
PLAY, AND WE'RE TRYING TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD. WE WANT TO DO THIS
QUICKLY, SO AGAIN, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND
HAPPY TO BE A COAUTHOR. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. CIERTO THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO WEIGH IN, I
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT US TRYING TO
HELP HOSPITALS AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR EVERYBODY,
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE THAT ARE HERE
TODAY, BECAUSE YOU ARE
EXPERIENCING SOMETHING THAT
OTHER PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING AS
WELL. AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
MACROECONOMICS OF OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM AND WHAT HAS BEEN
HAPPENING, WE CREATED THIS LOAN
PROGRAM TO, TO TRY TO SHORE UP
HOSPITALS THAT WERE IN TROUBLE.
BUT WE ALSO, CREATED A
CONSIDERABLE TAX THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO HELP RAISE MEDI-CAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATES, WHICH
ESPECIALLY FOR HOSPITALS THAT
ARE IMPACTED BY, LARGE
POPULATIONS OF MEDI-CAL
PATIENTS, AND EVEN INDIGENT
PATIENTS. THAT'S KIND OF THEIR
LIFELINE. AND WHEN WE STEER THAT
MONEY AWAY, THAT CREATES A THAT
CREATES FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. AND
WHEN WE ADD PEOPLE ON AND STEER
MONEY AWAY, THAT CREATES
ADDITIONAL HARDSHIP. AND SO IT'S
REALLY INCUMBENT ON US AS, AS
THE LEGISLATORS TO UNDERSTAND
THAT WHEN WE CREATE A TAX TO TRY
TO FIX A SYSTEM THAT WE'VE GOT
TO TRY TO FIX THAT SYSTEM FIRST,
WE CAN'T JUST KEEP PILING ON AND
THEN EXPECT EVERYBODY TO, TO
STAY AFLOAT. WE CAN'T EXPECT
DOCTORS, NURSES AND PERSONNEL TO
TAKE LESS AND LESS AND DO MORE
AND MORE WITH LESS PEOPLE. AND,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S $17 MILLION
LOAN FORGIVENESS. YOU KNOW THIS
IS GOING TO SUSPENSE. I HOPE IT
GETS OUT, BECAUSE IT IS
CERTAINLY AN EXAMPLE OF, WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN WE SHIFT MONEY AWAY
FROM FROM PROGRAMS THAT ARE
MEANT TO, TO SAVE THEM. AND, AND
I THINK, YOU KNOW, THIS SHOULD
BE ABLE TO BE ABSORBED IN THE
MONEY THAT WE STEERED OUT OF THE
MCO TAX AWAY FROM, THE INTENDED
PROGRAM THIS YEAR, AND, AND
ENABLE US TO, YOU KNOW, AT LEAST
GET THIS TRANSACTION THROUGH
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT
RIGHT NOW IS GETTING A
TRANSACTION DONE, AND SO THAT
IS, IS, I THINK TAKES PRIORITY
OVER, SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHERE
WE ARE PUTTING MONEY INTO
HOSPITALS THAT MIGHT NOT BE
SAVED. WELL, THIS ONE CAN BE AND
IT'S CRITICAL. AND THERE ARE
OTHER AREAS IN THE STATE WHERE
WE HAVE EXACTLY THE SAME
SITUATION. AND SO WE DON'T WANT
THIS DOMINO EFFECT OF HOSPITALS
COLLAPSING. SO WE HAVE TO BE
VERY PICK AND CHOOSE WHERE,
WHERE THERE IS A LIFELINE FOR A
HOSPITAL. AND THIS CERTAINLY IS
A LIFELINE WHEN YOU HAVE AN
AGENCY READY TO OR A LARGER
ENTITY HEALTH PLAN READY TO TAKE
IT OVER AND CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES AND ALSO THE CAPITAL
NEEDED TO KEEP THE HOSPITAL
ALIVE. SO, SO WITH THAT, YOU
KNOW, I SUPER APPRECIATE I KNOW
HOW HARD YOU I MEAN, HOW FAR YOU
GUYS HAD TO DRIVE TO GET HERE
TODAY. AND WE ARE WE WILL ALL OF
US ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
ARE DEDICATED TO TRYING TO FIX
THIS SOLUTION BECAUSE WE ALL
HAVE HOSPITALS. WE ALL HAVE
PEOPLE IN OUR DISTRICTS THAT
THAT NEED, THIS SYSTEM FIXED.
AND FOR US TO FOCUS THE MONEY
THAT WE SAY WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS
ON IT, TO FIX IT, TO DO EXACTLY
THAT AND NOT STEER IT OUT TO
BAIL OUT OTHER PARTS OF THE
BUDGET. THANK YOU. VERY GOOD,
THE COUPLE OF THE SENATORS THAT
HAD TO LEAVE, THEY HAD OTHER
COMMITTEES THAT THEY SIT ON. SO
THEY WILL BE HERE EVENTUALLY,
BUT WE'RE GLAD THEY WERE HERE TO
ESTABLISH THE QUORUM. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, YOU MAY CONCLUDE JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU, SENATOR, FOR
ALL YOUR LEADERSHIP AND GUIDANCE
THROUGH THIS PROCESS. AS YOU
UNDERSTAND, ONCE A HOSPITAL
CLOSES, IT'S VERY DIFFICULT. IF
NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO REOPEN. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PREVENT HERE. SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S COMMENTS,
MY COLLEAGUE, SENATOR WAHAB, WHO
SHARES THIS AS A PRIORITY OF OUR
DISTRICT, LOOKING FORWARD TO
MOVING ON WITH THE PROCESS. AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY. AND THANK YOU TO
ALL MY CONSTITUENTS WHO DROVE
UP, AND, YOU KNOW, ARE HERE TO
FIGHT FOR OUR HOSPITAL. VERY
GOOD. THIS IS A Dð A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE YOU ALMOST GOT ME TO
DO PAST. YEAH, I KNOW, I KNOW.
SO THIS IS A SUSPENSE.
CANDIDATES CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE'LL PUT IT ON
SUSPENSE AND WE'LL BE LOOKING AT
THIS AGAIN. SO THANK YOU VERY,
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. SO WE'RE GOING
TO GO BACK TO OUR AGENDA, THE
NEXT UP. YES. SHOULD WE DO THAT
RIGHT NOW OR JUST WAIT TILL WE
FINALLY GET EVERYBODY HERE
BECAUSE WE GOT TO DO IT ANYWAY.
OH, I SEE YOU'RE RIGHT. YOU'RE
RIGHT. WE DON'T NEED. WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR, PEOPLE TO
EXIT, WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK AND
TAKE UP AB 311. IT IS, THE
MOTION. IT IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WE'RE GOING TO,
WITHOUT OBJECTION, MOVE IT TO
SUSPENSE. AB 457 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY THAT WE TOOK
UP, EARLIER. IT IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
IT TO SUSPENSE. AB 2587 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY. IT
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE THAT TO SUSPENSE. AB
2703 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. IT IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, THAT BILL WILL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE, THAT'S AB 2703 AB
3203 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3203 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 660 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 660 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AND
AB 2320 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2320 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AS WELL. SO
THAT BRINGS US UP TO AB 977 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 977?
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NØ FILE.
THERE IS NO FILE ON THIS, NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. AB 977 IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, 977 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 1284
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYBODY THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. THE TOTAL
ESTIMATED FISCAL IMPACT OF THE
BILL IS APPROXIMATELY $9.1
MILLION OF GENERAL FUND IN 25,
26 AND 9.4 MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND BEGINNING IN 2627 AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER, MAINLY
ASSOCIATED WITH THE NEED FOR
38.5 PERMANENT POSITIONS.
ADDITIONALLY, IT CREATES
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES BY
ESTABLISHING A PRONOUNCED
EXPECTATION THAT THE NATURAL
RESOURCE AGENCY AND ITS
DEPARTMENTS, CONSERVANCIES AND
COMMISSIONS ENGAGE WITH
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
NEGOTIATIONS ON CO-GOVERNANCE
AND CO-MANAGEMENT AGREEMENTS AS
AUTHORIZED. VERY GOOD, BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THERE'S
NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS, AB
1284 IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
1284 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
1510 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR
MEMBERS. SAM NASH ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION, SUPPORT. VERY GOOD.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO. FILE OKAY. WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
AND THERE'S NO QUESTIONS OR
CONCERN. AB 1510 IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 1510 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 1788 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NÓ FILE.
VERY GOOD. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AND AB 1788 IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 1788 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 1789 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NÓ FILE. VERY GOOD.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THIS FILE IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1789 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 2038 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. FINANCE NOTES THAT
THE STATE PARKS AND RECREATION
FUND, OR SPPF, IS STRUCTURALLY
IMBALANCED, WITH EXPENDITURES
EXCEEDING REVENUES BY
APPROXIMATELY $28 MILLION IN
2425 AND IS UNABLE TO
SUSTAINABLY ABSORB ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURES OR ANY LOSS OF
REVENUE. TO THE EXTENT THIS BILL
RESULTS IN FEWER SPECIAL EVENT
PERMITS AND APPLICABLE FEES, THE
BILL MAY RESULT IN A LOSS OF
REVENUE TO THE SPUR, WHICH
SUPPORTS THE OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE OF THE STATE PARK
SYSTEM. ADDITIONALLY, FINANCE
NOTES THAT BY LIMITING THE
DEPARTMENT'S DISCRETION TO
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE EVENTS WITHIN
A STATE PARK UNIT, THIS BILL
COULD DRIVE SIGNIFICANT BUT
UNQUANTIFIABLE COSTS TO SPPF.
VERY GOOD. BRINGING THIS BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2038 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 1791 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER. WEBER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ FILE. BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 1791, WE'LL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. AB 1808 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NGUYEN. IS THERE ANY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER? NGUYEN HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION? IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THIS BILL MAY RESULT IN UNKNOWN
BUT SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
COSTS IN THE RANGE OF TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. AT A
MINIMUM, THESE POTENTIAL COSTS
MAY MATERIALIZE TO THE EXTENT OF
FAMILY WHO WOULD WHO WOULD HAVE
EXITED THE PROGRAM UNDER THE 12
MONTH ELIGIBILITY PERIOD
PURSUANT TO CURRENT LAW,
CONTINUES TO PARTICIPATE UNDER
THE 24 MONTH ELIGIBILITY PERIOD
PURSUANT TO THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS, WE'LL BRING THIS
BILL BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. IT
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 1808 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 3042 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NGUYEN WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NÓ FILE. WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3042 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
AB 1831 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NÓ FILE.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. AND THIS BILL. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1831 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2057 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NÓ FILE. WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE AS WELL. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2057 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 2511 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NØ FILE. BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. BILL IS, A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2511. YES.
WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING
ON TO AB 2768. AGAIN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? PARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
ALLOWING THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT RECIPIENTS TO
MATRICULATE INTO THE PRIVATE
SECTOR WOULD UNDERMINE THE
PURPOSE OF THE INVESTMENT. THE
GSG PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED BY
THE 2020 BUDGET ACT TO ADDRESS
TEACHER SHORTAGES IN THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS BY
PROVIDING GRANTS TO ENCOURAGE
TEACHER WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
FINANCE ALSO NOTES THAT ARTICLE
NINE, SECTION EIGHT OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION,
PROHIBITS PUBLIC MONEY FROM
BEING APPROPRIATED TO ANY
SECTARIAN, DENOMINATIONAL, OR
OTHER OTHERWISE NON PUBLIC
SCHOOL WHILE TSG AWARDS WILL NOT
DIRECTLY BE FUNDING ACTIVITIES
AT THE NONPUBLIC, NONSECTARIAN,
SECTARIAN SCHOOLS MENTIONED IN
THIS BILL, THE EXPANSION OF THE
ELIGIBILITY TO THESE NONPUBLIC
SITES DOES NOT ALIGN WITH
HISTORIC PRECEDENT TO KEEP
PUBLIC DOLLARS AT PUBLIC SCHOOLS
. WE'LL BRING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2768 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. OKAY, MOVING ON TO AB
1874 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANCHEZ.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NØ FILE. WE'LL BRING
THIS BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. AND
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITH THAT
OBJECTION, AB 1874 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 1877 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACKSON. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACKSON HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
1877? HOW ABOUT AN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NÓ FILE.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 1877 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 1967, AGAIN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL,
AS IT WOULD RESULT IN STATE
OPERATION COSTS OF $223,000.
GENERAL FUND. IN 25, 26 AND
247,000. GENERAL FUND ONGOING.
BEGINNING IN 2627 TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
CREATE THE POSITION OF FOOD
INSECURITY OFFICER, OKAY, THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 1967 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2501 AS I
INDICATED TO YOU PREVIOUSLY, AB
1886 HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM THE
FILE AND AB 2501 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL? IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL.
OKAY BRINGING THAT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2501 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. WE'RE GOING TO SKIP
OVER AB 1901, THIS HAS A DUE
PASS RECOMMENDATION, AND WE'RE
GOING TO WAIT FOR THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. I BELIEVE HE'S HE WANTED
TO BE HERE TODAY MOVING ON TO AB
1911 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? THIS IS A
SUSPENSE, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
GOING TOO FAST. SORRY. NO. IT'S
OKAY. THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS NEUTRAL, BUT WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE SOME CONCERNS. THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
ESTIMATES A ONE TIME FISCAL
IMPACT TOTALING $115,000 TO THE
MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT. AND
FINANCE NOTES THAT THE NBA IS
CURRENTLY OPERATING WITH A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT, BASED ON
PROJECTIONS DEVELOPED AS PART OF
THE 24 BUDGET, THE RESERVES IN
THE NBA MAY BE EXHAUSTED AS SOON
AS THE FISCAL YEAR 2526. ANY
INCREASE IN NBA EXPENDITURES
WILL EXACERBATE FISCAL PRESSURES
ON THE FUND. I'M SORRY, BUT I
BELIEVE THAT WE'RE WE GOT OUR
BILLS MIXED UP. Ó, I BELIEVE
THAT'S THE, THE CHEN BILL. BILL
THAT WE SKIPPED. OH, WE SKIPPED
THAT ONE. MY APOLOGIES, MADAM.
THAT'S OKAY. WE'LL GO BACK AND
PICK THAT UP LATER. WE'RE ON
1911. THANK YOU. RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES. OKAY, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THAT BILL. OKAY. AND IT'S THE
TO THE BILL AS DSS ESTIMATES,
THE BILL WILL RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY 70.4
MILLION IN 2526 AND 63.1 MILLION
IN 2627 AND 62.4 MILLION IN
2728, AND ONGOING TO MEET THE
REQUIRED INVESTIGATION,
NOTIFICATION AND ADJUDICATION OF
NEW APPEALS. VERY GOOD. BRING
THAT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE, THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE.
AND SO AB 1911. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE'LL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 2165
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL,
ALTHOUGH THE ADDITIONAL STEPS
FALL WITHIN THE GENERAL SCOPE OF
EXISTING SCHOOL COUNSELOR DUTIES
REQUIRING LEAS TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL STEPS BEFORE A
STUDENT MAY OPT OUT OF THE FAFSA
OR CAÑADA REQUIREMENT AND POST
SPECIFIED INFORMATION TO THEIR
WEBSITES COULD CONSTITUTE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE WITH
UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT PROP 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS THAT COULD BE IN THE
MILLIONS TO TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, DEPENDING ON UPON THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS SEEKING AN
EXEMPTION. VERY GOOD. WE'LL
BRING YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2165 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2440 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
FINANCE NOTES THAT BY SPECIFYING
THE ACQUISITION AND STEWARDSHIP
OF STATE LAND AS A PRIORITY
ACTION TO ACHIEVE THE 30 BY 30
GOAL, THIS BILL CREATES
IMPLEMENTATION EXPECTATIONS THAT
WILL CREATE SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL COST PRESSURES IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION OR OTHER STATE
AGENCIES TO ACQUIRE AND MANAGE
NEW STATE LANDS. VERY GOOD.
WE'LL BRING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, AND IT IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITH THAT
OBJECTION, AB 2440, WE'LL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. AB 1979 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD, WHO WAS WAIVED.
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NÓ FILE.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1979 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2005 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NØ FILE.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2005 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 1992 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERNER, THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? BUT
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NØ FILE. BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 1992 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 2020 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NÓ FILE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2020 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2074 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? SAM NASSER
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. SUPPORT
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS OPPOSED THIS BILL AS
IT CREATES ONE TIME AND ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COST OF $501,000 IN
2526, $492,000 IN 2627, AND
RESPECTIVELY, FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TO FUND POSITIONS
THAT WOULD DEVELOP THE STATEWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN AND ASSIST
LEAS IN IMPLEMENTING THE PLAN.
BRINGING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2074 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2112 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS NEUTRAL, BUT HAS A
FEW CONCERNS WITH THE BILL. VERY
GOOD. BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. AB 2112 IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2112 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN
WILL GO BACK TO YOUR BILL, WHICH
IS AB 1901. WELCOME AND THIS IS
A DUE PASS RECOMMENDATION. THE
ONLY ONE OF THE DAY. SO YOU
SHOULD FEEL VERY SPECIAL. OH, I
FEEL VERY SPECIAL TO BE IN YOUR
PRESENCE, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AGAIN AND
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB
1901. THIS BILL CREATES A
PROCESS FOR SALVAGE POOLS IN THE
DMV TO ALLOW ABANDONED VEHICLES
TO HAVE TITLE, PROCESS, AND MORE
STREAMLINED WAY. FROM 2016 TO
2023, SALVAGE POOLS COULD
PROCESS ABANDONED VEHICLES
DIRECTLY WITH THE DMV. BUT LAST
YEAR, DMV REALIZED THEY LACKED
THE STATUTORY AUTHOR FOR THAT
PROCESS AND REPEALED THAT
PROCESS. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
CREATE A PROCESS THAT ONCE AGAIN
TIMELY PROCESS THESE ABANDONED
VEHICLE TITLES. WE HAVE HAPPILY
ENGAGED WITH DMV AND BELIEVE
THAT THE FISCAL COST TO THE
DEPARTMENT ARE REASONABLE WITH
RESPECT TO THIS NEW PROCESS. WE
APPRECIATE THEIR ENGAGEMENT AND
HERE TO TESTIFY WITH ME IS CLIFF
CLAWSON, WHO REPRESENTS
REPRESENT COPART. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WELCOME, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS CLIFF COSTA, TODAY ON
BEHALF OF COPART, WE APPRECIATE
THE ENGAGEMENT THE DMV HAS GIVEN
US. WE LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ON THEIR CONCERNS THAT HE'S
ALREADY MENTIONED AND WILL
MENTION AGAIN. AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, TO CORRECT THE
RECORD FOR AB NINE 1901, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
NEUTRAL, BUT WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT AGAIN, THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES ESTIMATES A ONE
TIME FISCAL IMPACT TOTALING
$115,000 FOR THE NBA. AND
FINANCE NOTES THAT THE NBA IS
CURRENTLY OPERATING WITH THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT, BASED ON
PROJECTIONS DEVELOPED AS PART OF
THE 24 BUDGET, THE RESERVES IN
THE NBA MAY BE EXHAUSTED AS SOON
AS THE FISCAL YEAR 2526. VERY
GOOD. I'M GOING TO BRING THIS
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. THERE IS A MOTION. YES,
THIS IS A Dð PASS, ANY
QUESTIONS? IF NOT, YOU MAY
CONCLUDE Ó. OKAY. VERY GOOD.
I'M GOOD, I'M GOOD. I'M SORRY.
OKAY. HE WAS GOING TO ASK A
REALLY TOUGH QUESTION SO I COULD
SEE HE RESTRAINED HIMSELF. I'M
SCARED. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
FOR PROTECTING ME. YES, MADAM
CHAIR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR HELP. AND GUIDANCE. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
D¯ÚI ON THE CONCERNS THAT THEY
DO HAVE. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
VERY GOOD. THERE IS A MOTION.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE FLOOR
. CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. JONES. I JONES. AYE. ASHBY.
BECKER BRADFORD. CIERTO. CIERTO.
AYE WAHAB. THE BILL HAS THREE
VOTES. WE'LL PUT IT ON. CALL FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU. OKAY.
GOING BACK TO OUR AGENDA, THE
NEXT BILL UP IS AB 2103 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN WHO HAS
WAIVED THE PRESENTATION. ANYONE
HERE IN TEST THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION ESTIMATE THAT THIS
BILL WILL RESULT IN UNKNOWN, BUT
LIKELY SIGNIFICANT COSTS RELATED
TO THE REQUIREMENT TO HOST
PUBLIC MEETINGS. EACH MEETING IS
ESTIMATED TO COST AROUND
$12,000, BASED ON THE ACTUAL
COST OF HOLDING SIMILAR PUBLIC
MEETINGS. FINANCE CONCURS WITH
THIS ESTIMATE, AND ALSO NOTES
CONCERN THAT THE BILL MAY RESULT
IN ADDITIONAL COSTS BECAUSE OF
REDUCED OVERSIGHT IN THE
ACQUISITION PROCESS, EXEMPTING
ACQUISITIONS FROM THE STATE
PUBLIC WORKS BOARD OVERSIGHT
REMOVES AN IMPORTANT LAYER OF
REVIEW THAT, AMONG OTHER THINGS,
ANALYZES PROPERTIES FOR
POTENTIAL STATE LIABILITIES THAT
WOULD RESULT FROM THE
ACQUISITION. VERY GOOD, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS, A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2103 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2249 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? WELCOME ETHAN NAGLER
I'M HALF THE CITY CLERK'S
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. VERY GOOD. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
? DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NÓ FILE
BACK. BRINGING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2249 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2109 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2109 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2245 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE IN IN, AGREEMENT. FORGOT
MY LANGUAGE. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
BY INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES CLASSIFIED AS
PERMANENT, THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE UNKNOWN, BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT PROP 98 GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES. SHOULD THE
PROGRAMS ENCOUNTER ADDITIONAL
DUE PROCESS HEARINGS RELATED TO
THE DISMISSAL OR OTHER DISMISSAL
PROCEEDINGS. BRINGING THIS BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE, THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO AB
2245 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2144 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GREYSON,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
THOSE IN SUPPORT, THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NÓ FILE. BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2144 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND AB 2161 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ FILE. BRINGING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2161 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2167 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. THOSE
IN SUPPORT, THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. FINANCE ESTIMATES
SIGNIFICANT LIMITED TERM SPECIAL
FUND RESOURCES IN THE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ARE NEEDED
TO CHANGE THE SCOPE OF THE ED
NEXT TO INCORPORATE THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
BRINGING THIS BACK TO COMMITTEE,
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE AB 2167 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 2279 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NØ. FILE BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE AB 2279 IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, IT WILL MOVE
TO AB 2279 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2178 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NØ. FILE BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, 2178 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2483 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NØ. FILE
BRINGING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITH THAT
OBJECTION, 2483 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 2181 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN SUPPORT?
WELCOME THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS PAMELA
GIBBS, REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THE BILL IS SIMILAR TO
A BILL FROM LAST SESSION,
RELATED TO HIGHLY MOBILE YOUTH
WHO WANTED TO GRADUATE WITH
THEIR LOCAL DIPLOMA REQUIREMENTS
AND THIS BILL OFFERS PARITY FOR
JUVENILE COURT, SCHOOL PUPILS.
WE APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS BY
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND BELIEVE
THIS BILL CAN BE PERFORMED
WITHIN REASONABLE MEASURES.
SINCE WE'RE ALREADY PROVIDING
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES TO THESE
STUDENTS IN ADDITION, I'D LIKE
TO ALSO EXPRESS BEING AUTHORIZED
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS. THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS OPPOSED THIS BILL.
FINANCE ESTIMATED THAT THIS BILL
COULD RESULT IN ONGOING
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS OF UP TO $10 MILLION. THIS
ESTIMATE IS BASED ON A POTENTIAL
INCREASE IN LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA. COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ADDED
ATTENDANCE THAT MAY BE GENERATED
BY JUVENILE COURT SCHOOL
STUDENTS THAT CHOOSE TO CONTINUE
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION
BEYOND THEIR FOUR YEAR UPON
RELEASE FROM A JUVENILE COURT
FACILITY, BRINGING THIS BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2181 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2465 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ PHÐ. BRINGING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2465 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2202 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RENDON, IS THERE
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT ABOUT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NÓ FILE.
BRINGING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2202. WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2258 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ZABIR. THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS. CATHY
CENTRELINK MCDONALD FOR THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE ESTIMATES
THAT THE TOTAL COST OF THIS BILL
IS TO BE APPROXIMATELY $64,000
IN 25, 26, 133,000IN 2627
THROUGH 2728, AND 189,000 IN 28,
29 AND 229,000 2930. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTES THAT
TO THE EXTENT THE MEDI-CAL
MANAGED HEALTH PLANS CHOOSE OR
ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
PREVENTATIVE SERVICES EXCEEDING
FEDERAL RECOMMENDATION, THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES ON MEDI-CAL.
BRINGING THIS BACK TO COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2258 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. WE
TOOK UP AB 2271, SO WE'RE ON TO
AB 2281. ARE WE OKAY? I I
THOUGHT WE DID BECAUSE MEMBER
ASHBY AND BECKER SHOWED UP. YES
THAT'S OKAY. WE'RE JUST MAKING
SURE WE TOOK ACTION ON AB 2271.
AND I BELIEVE WE DID. SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON NOW TO AB 2281
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORIA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOTO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT AN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NØ FILE. BRINGING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2281 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2210 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ FILE. BRINGING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2310 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2311 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
WE SPECIFICALLY NOTE THAT THE
PROGRAM ACTIVITY WOULD NOT OCCUR
UNTIL AN APPROPRIATION HAS BEEN
MADE BY THE LEGISLATURE, BUT TO
THE EXTENT IT DOES OCCUR,
CALRECYCLE ESTIMATES THAT THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF THIS BILL WOULD
BE APPROXIMATELY $269,000 OF
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
FOR TWO LIMITED TERM POSITIONS
FOR 25, 26 AND 2627 AND 2728.
BRINGING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2311 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 2313
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION, IS
THERE ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FILE BRINGING THIS
BACK TO COMMITTEE. THE BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2313 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. ON TO AB 2388
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOE PATTERSON
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOE PATTERSON
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? NO FILE.
BRINGING THIS BACK TO COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL IS SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2288 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
2388 AB 2589 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JOE PATTERSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ FILE. BRINGING YOU
BACK. BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2589 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2398 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION
? DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NÓ FILE
BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2398 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 3021 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NØ FILE. BRINGING IT
THE MATTER BACK TO COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3021 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 3282. THIS IS A
JUDICIARY. JUDICIARY BILL. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ FILE. BRINGING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3282 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2410 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLACE, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION ANYONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ FILE. BRING YOU BACK
TO COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2410 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2427 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT ETHAN ENGLER ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF FOSTER CITY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IN
OPPOSITION. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NØ FILE. BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2427 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2565 AGAIN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NÓ FILE.
BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2565 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 3131 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NÓ FILE. BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3131 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2428 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
IN SUPPORT? THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS. CATHY SONDERLING
MCDONNELL, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF ADULT
DAY SERVICES, THEY'RE THE
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS THE
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES,
OR C BASE PROVIDERS. THERE ARE
ABOUT 300 OF THESE PROVIDERS
STATEWIDE. THEY SERVE ABOUT
40,000 VERY DIVERSE CALIFORNIANS
, AND THEY ARE ONLY ABLE TO DO
SO THROUGH MEDI-CAL AND THROUGH
RELATIONSHIPS WITH MANAGED CARE
PLANS. THEY'RE SPONSORING THIS
BILL. WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND YOUR CONSIDERATION WHILE
IT'S ON SUSPENSE? BECAUSE THE
ISSUE IS THAT THERE WAS A CUT OF
10% DURING THE GREAT RECESSION.
IT WAS RESTORED IN 2019. THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AGREED. AND NOT ALL OF THE
HEALTH PLANS, THOUGH, HAVE
PASSED THE RESTORATION ON TO THE
PROVIDERS. SO WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO WOULD SAY, IF THERE'S A
RESTORATION OF THIS KIND,
THERE'S A RATE SET THAT SHOULD
BE A FLOOR. YOU SHOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO PAY BELOW IT. AS SOME
PLANS CONTINUE TO DO. WE'RE
TRYING TO GET THEM TO DO THE
RIGHT THING, BUT REALLY THERE IS
NOTHING TO COMPEL THEM TO DO
THAT. AND THIS BILL WOULD ENABLE
SCADS AND THEIR MEMBERS TO
ACTUALLY COMPEL THE PLANS TO PAY
AT LEAST THAT FLOOR. THEY COULD
PAY ABOVE IT, OF COURSE, BUT
SOME ARE BELOW IT, AND WE DON'T
THINK THAT THAT'S APPROPRIATE
NOR CONSISTENT WITH THE SPIRIT
OR INTENT OF WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AGREED TO IN 2019. SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. IT'S A
RELATIVELY, RELATIVELY SMALL
GROUP OF PROVIDERS, BUT THIS IS
A REALLY BIG DEAL FOR THEM. SOME
OF THEM WILL BE FORCED TO CLOSE
IF WE'RE NOT GETTING THE RATE
INCREASES, OR AT LEAST PAYING
THEM THE INCREASES THAT WE'VE
ALREADY ACHIEVED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IN OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NÓ PHÐ. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2428.
WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2447
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALENCIA. THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VALENCIA HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NÓ FILE.
BRINGING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2447 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2518 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ FILE. BRING YOU BACK
TO COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2518 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2519 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MANCINI, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NÓ FILE.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE AB 2519. WE'LL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2549 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NØ FILE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB
2549 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2750 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL,
AS IT IS OPPOSED DUE TO THE BILL
EXTENDING BIOMASS CONTRACTS,
WHICH WILL LEAD TO INCREASED
COSTS FOR RATEPAYERS TO SUPPORT
THE REQUIRED PROCUREMENT OF
RESOURCES BY ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS. VERY GOOD.
BRINGING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2750 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 2595
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US,
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THAT OF
HER BILL? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NØ FILE. BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2595 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2693 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ FILE. BRINGING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2693 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2734 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CONNELLY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY HAS WAIVED.
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. CDFA ESTIMATES
ONGOING ANNUAL COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY $200,000. GENERAL
FUND TO HIRE ONE SENIOR
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENTIST TO
OVERSEE THE LONGER TERM, LONGER
TERMS OF ON FARM DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS. ADDITIONALLY, FINANCE
ALSO NOTES THAT THIS BILL WILL
RESULT IN POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
AND PRESSURES IN THE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO EXPAND
THE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM. WE'LL
BRING THIS BACK TO COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2734 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB
2766 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO. FILE. BRINGING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2766 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2830 BY SPEAKER
RIVAS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A CURRENT POSITION ON THE
BILL. HOWEVER, WE WOULD FLAG
THAT THE BILL COULD RESULT IN
COST OF UPWARDS OF $1 MILLION OF
GENERAL FUND FOR THE AUTOMATION
RELATED TO THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM, CALIFORNIA AUTOMATED
RESPONSE AND ENGAGEMENT SYSTEM,
AND POTENTIALLY THE GUARDIAN
BACKGROUND CHECK SYSTEM. THIS,
BRINGING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB
2830 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2873 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. A
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 2873 WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 2906 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT? IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. THIS BILL RESULTS
IN ESTIMATED COUNTY COSTS OF
$341,000, OF WHICH 186,000 IS
GENERAL FUND. IN 2425, $604,000
IN 2526, OF WHICH 379,000 IS
GENERAL FUND AND $263,000 IN 26,
27 AND ONGOING, OF WHICH
$193,000 IS GENERAL FUND, FOR
THE INCREASE IN ADMINISTRATIVE
WORKLOAD TO THE COUNTY CHILD
CARE, CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES,
AND FOR NECESSARY ONE TIME
AUTOMATION CHANGES TO THE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES SYSTEM.
BRINGING THIS BACK TO COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL IS SUBJECT IS, A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE? WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 2906 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE AB 3217 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN. ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
FINANCE. NO FOUL. BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3272. I'M
AT 3217. WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 3004 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE
FONG, THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NÓ FILE. BRINGING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 3004 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 3182 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NØ PHÐ.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE AS WELL. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB 3182 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AND FINALLY AB 3229 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ FILE. BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 3229 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. WELL THAT
PRETTY MUCH CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA
ITEMS FOR THE DAY. WE HAVE A
BILL ON CALL. SO, FIRST, LET ME
THANK EVERYBODY FOR WHO CAME
SHOWED UP TO TESTIFY TODAY. LET
ME THANK THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR BEING HERE AS WELL.
VERY HELPFUL, HELPFUL COMMENTS.
WE WILL TAKE A BRIEF RECESS. SO
WE CAN ALLOW PEOPLE TO ADD ON.
SURE OKAY. VERY GOOD. WELL, WHY
DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND CALL, THE
ONE CASE THAT HAD A DO PASS
MOTION. IT IS AB 1901 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN. AGAIN, THE
MOTION IS TO PASS ASHBY BECKER,
BRADFORD Ã BRADFORD I WAHAB.
WAHAB I THAT BILL HAS FIVE VOTES
AND WE'LL PUT IT BACK ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I LOVE
MÁS. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A BRIEF
RECESS.
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IS BACK IN ORDER,
WE'RE FINISHING UP THE LAST. THE
ONE BILL THAT HAD A DO PASS
MOTION, WHICH IS AB 1901 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
ASHBY. BECKER A BECKER. I THAT,
VOTE IS 6 TO 0. AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR OUR AGENDA FOR
TODAY AND THE VOTES FOR TODAY.
THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY FOR,
BEING HERE. AND WE ARE ADJOURNED
. THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.